el próximo domingo más de 300 ciudades
ofrecen transporte gratuito para que
cerca de 95 millones de brasileños
puedan acudir a votar sin tener que
pagar es un porcentaje significativo en
un país que tiene 212 millones de
habitantes y 156 millones de lectores
esta medida persigue dos objetivos por
un lado disminuir la abstensión que la
primera vuelta alcanzó el 21% es decir
32 millones de personas no acudieron a
las urnas y también se quiere dar una
ayuda a los más pobres que no tienen el
dinero para el billete del autobús hay
que recordar que antes de la primera
vuelta el presidente Yahir bolsonaro
acudió con una petición al tribunal
superior electoral para evitar esta
gratuidad porque es sabido que los más
pobres votan al expresidente Luis
Ignacio López Silva el Tribunal Superior
electoral rechazó esta petición y
posteriormente la Corte Suprema autorizó
a los municipios a ofrecer transportes
gratuitos entonces veremos el domingo si
esto incentiva el voto porque el voto de
los indecisos y de las personas que se
abstienen puede ser decisivo en estas
elecciones Además este año hemos tenido
un número
récord de denuncias por accesorio
electoral es decir empresarios que
intentan secuestrar el voto de sus
empleados a cambio de dinero eso está
aconteciendo sobre todo los estados del
noroeste que son nulistas hay
empresarios que requieren los documentos
de sus empleados y los devuelven solo el
lunes después de las elecciones a cambio
de dinero de momento yo Ha habido
algunas condenas la última en el estado
del Paraná en amazonía donde un
empresario ha sido condenado a pagar
9.400 dólares por esta práctica